[Musique]
ceausescu et sa femme ont été exécutés
tout à l'heure c'est la télévision
roumaine qui l'a annoncé il était 19
heures 40
l'aide aux roumains affluent en france
mais aussi dans d'autres pays dans ce
journal lionel jospin premier ministre
par intérim explications au panama le
général noriega réfugié à l'ambassade du
vatican la nonciature c'est une victoire
bien amère pour les américains
bonsoir la nouvelle nous est parvenue il
ya 20 minutes à peine sur nos
téléscripteurs et nos ordinateurs je
vous lis le texte de cette dépêche
le dictateur roumain nicolae ceausescu
et sa femme elena ont été exécutés lundi
au terme d'un procès secrets pour des
crimes particulièrement graves contre la
roumanie
c'était radio milliards est qu'il
annonce c'est donc l'information
principale de ce soir à propos de la
roumanie
très précisément la télévision roumaine
a annoncé la nouvelle tout à l'heure en
direct à des millions de roumains
voici comment cela s'est passé écouter
cet extrait de la télévision tout de
suite nous écoutons cet extrait de la
télévision
dans un instant tout de suite dans une
minute mème pas dans quelques secondes
nous allons voir cet extrait de la
télévision c'était il y a simplement 20
minutes et nous avons le temps de
recaler nos images voici comment le
sticker anus et elena ceausescu au poste
condamné la mort fait chic on vise qu'à
leur avis sentenza annemasse définitive
je suis un poste exécuta voilà donc
c'est l annonce de l'exécution du
dictateur ceausescu et de sa femme tout
à l'heure à la télévision roumaine après
plusieurs jours de violents combats
bucarest la capitale mais aussi dans la
plupart des villes de province la
situation semblait se calmer un petit
peu aujourd'hui les insurgés soutenus
par l'armée roumaine prenaient peu à peu
le contrôle du pays bien sûr il ya
encore de très nombreuses affrontements
car un peu partout les derniers membres
de la securitate sont traqués mais ils
défendent chèrement leur peau alors tout
de suite nous allons à bucarest en
direct où se trouve la nos envoyés
spéciaux
patricia cause patrice lacoste est ce
qu'on parle bien sûr déjà de l'exécution
de nicholas chasse aux scoops
oui hervé l'exécution est confirmée nous
en avons eu confirmation ici à
l'ambassade de france par le biais d'un
coup de téléphone à l'ambassadeur alors
à l'extérieur on n'entend pas les
immenses rumeurs qui ont parcouru la
ville toute la journée
j'étais en fait des cris de victoire des
manifestants
ce soir la nuit est tombée donc c'est de
nouveau le règne des francs tireurs
il y en a au dessus de l'ambassade de
france niché dans le toit d'une église
hall clocher et nous sommes donc obligés
d'être ici dans un des bureaux de
l'ambassade de france
voilà alors patricia nous vous
retrouvons dans un instant donc vous
êtes à l'intérieur de l'ambassade de
france vous le précise y est vous allez
tout à l'heure nous raconter comment
vous avez vécu cette journée à bucarest
mais tout de suite quelques images de la
télévision roumaine c'est ce qui se
passe quotidiennement dans les villes
roumaines les fidèles de chaouch et
secoue son trac et je voulais dire et
ils tentent de fuir ou de s'échapper
alors voici l'une de ses scènes filmées
sur le vix je vais vous expliquer sur le
vif par la télévision roumaine
voici l'une de ses scènes l'homme que
vous allez voir est un poète célèbre en
roumanie mais il était très proche du
régime ceausescu il était donc très
riche mais très impliqué il tente
maintenant de convaincre les autres
qu'il soutient les insurgés
regardez attendez la fin des combats
n'oubliez pas les consignes de l'armée
ne lui compliquer pas la tâche dans la
tourmente de la surrection un poète
officielle prise au piège et qui tente
de gagner du temps
il était 17h30 heure locale cet après
midi lorsque quelqu'un dans une rue de
bucarest assure g a soudain reconnu
l'illustrent adrian paunescu écrivain
choyée par le régime
ouvert de gloire et de richesse par le
dictateur déchu il promet aujourd'hui de
s'expliquer il tente de rattraper le
vent de l'histoire sans grand succès
[Musique]
n'écoutez pas pas ou n'est ce coup c'est
lui qui vous a crétiniser abba pas ou
n'est ce coup n'écoutez pas ce criminel
tout à coup les tirs reprennent le cri
d'une femme dans la foule mettez vous à
l'abri je vous en prie et puis la
panique un instant adrian pas ou n'est
ce coup à tenter d'en profiter pour
échapper à la colère
son but le consulat des états unis où il
veut se réfugier à quelques dizaines de
mètres de là quelques dizaines de mètres
et la vis aux peut-être mais autour de
lui la foule s'est refermé comme un étau
l'ancien chouchou du dictateur n'est
plus qu'un gros sommes dérisoires qui ne
sait pas s'il va sauver sa peau santé
lui dessus
ah bah pas ou n'est ce coup créé les uns
tandis que d'autres le protège dents
rempart de corps pour éviter le pire
[Musique]
quelques coups de feu en l'air ce sont
les soldats qui gardent le consulat et
qui le paye enfin sous leur protection
le poète qui ne disait pas la vérité ne
sera pas exécutée c'était en fin d'après
midi à bucarest des images tournées par
l'une de nos équipes à bucarest la donne
en effet une idée des scènes terribles
qui se multiplient pour le reste c'est
vrai la journée était un petit peu plus
calme je vous le disais en commençant ce
journal voici les images de ce retour
progressif à la normale jean-marc il use
comme pour effacer le souvenir des
angoisses de la nuit des petits gestes
des petits riens mais qui témoigne que
pour la première fois ce matin place du
palais dans le centre de bucarest
on pouvait enfin revivre sans risque et
l'assassinât sournois par un franc
tireur de la securitate
[Musique]
ici la joue encore ceausescu
c'est fini et là des sapins des
guirlandes surgi de nulle part
et oui ce sont de vrais journaux trois
titres différents quatre peut-être et
qui n'assène pas tous la même rengaine
mais il ne s'agit pas de rêver tout
juste le temps d'éteindre les incendies
né des combats de la nuit dans une
capitale roumaine où les tirs n'ont pas
totalement cessé surtout dans les
banlieues nord et sud est près du
ministère de la défense
[Musique]
la principale information ce soir c'est
bien sur l'exécution de nicolae
ceausescu et sa femme exécution qui a
été annoncé tout à l'heure par la
télévision roumaine
l'homme qui a régné pendant 23 ans sur
la roumanie a donc été exécuté tout à
leur rappel de ses années de tyrannie
maryse manie même mickey à courtiser
chez oc secours c'était en 1972 lors de
la visite du président nixon à l'ancien
apprenti cordonnier
à l'époque tous les grands du bloc de
l'ouest rendent hommage à ce
nationaliste roumain qui sait dire non à
moscou en 68 le général de gaulle est
reçue en triomphe à bucarest
cette année-là ceausescu s'oppose à
l'entrée des chars soviétiques à prague
l'étoile du dirigeant roumain monte au
firmament d'autant que le pays connaît
une période de vaches grasses on
industrialise on s'endette le niveau de
vie s'améliore
et puis le masque tombe derrière
l'indépendant le non alignés pointe le
stand junien paranoïaque
premier signe en 77 l'armée roumaine
réprime dans le sang une grève des
mineurs
on s'aperçoit que toutes les familles
chaussée ce coup s'est approprié les
postes clés du pouvoir
despotisme corruption en classe
désormais le conducteur dans la
catégorie des dictateurs sanguinaires
les roumains enfin les roumains ont peur
seul l'iran aux encore recevoir celui
qui se fait appeler le génie des
carpates
mais le génie n'a plus pour très
longtemps retour à bucarest tout de
suite en direct vous savez en effet que
depuis hier soir nous sommes en direct
avec la capitale roumaine antenne 2 fr3
les deux sociétés de services publics
avec leurs moyens leurs techniciens
aussi ce tdf ont mises en place dès
vendredi dernier les moyens de vous
transmettre cette actualité donc en
direct alors nous retrouvons là bas
patricia cost patricia vous nous le
disiez tout à l'heure
l'accalmie est précaire en raison des
francs tireurs qui sont un peu partout
oui non pas là la tension a beaucoup
baissé cela vie le soir c'est vrai les
rues sont complètement désertes car l
armée et les francs-tireurs tire sur
tout ce qui bouge tout le monde a peur
de se faire attaquer comment avez vous
vécu cet homme-là pour l'instant il n'y
a aucune réaction donc là l'exécution de
chez touché sco et sa femme c'est le
royaume des francs tireurs la nuit les
ombres et la peur je crois que vous
vouliez nous montrer comment vous avez
vécu cette journée est ce que les
équipes ont pu tournus oui d'ailleurs
pour les équipes je tiens à citer franck
brisset qui a fait le premier reportage
là je vais vous montrer un reportage de
françoise joly de jean-françois hoffman
et de rené gasparini
c'est un reportage sur la journée qui
est le 25 décembre jour où les romains
travail car c'est une fête qui ne se
fait pas officiellement à l'épreuve du
toucher ce coup un noël très triste
personne en fait on avait le coeur à se
réjouir
les caméras contre caen match la douleur
pour ce premier noël de la liberté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet appui du car est enterré ses
premiers morts ces sommes j'ai pas ses
enfants tombés sous les balles des
unités spéciales de ceausescu et des
corps retrouvés par les familles dans
des hôpitaux à la morgue mais aussi
parfois entassés dans des jardins
publics et les cimetières de la ville où
nous suffisent plus alors cet homme sera
enterré à 60 mètres du palais
présidentiel dans un jardin public
aménagé en cimetière la population y
creusent des combes à ce seul endroit
nous en compterons près de 200
lucas reste aujourd'hui encore du mal à
recenser le nombre exact que c'est la
zone martin dans toute la ville la
population dressent des chapelles
ardentes ce recueil là où sont morts
notamment qu'aucune étude de la vente ma
émotions je me fais de mal ne met pas
trouvé mêlé moi mais je ne peux pas
rester à la maison dans ses poumons
je savais qu'ils vont en boîte bien ici
et je vais vous expliquer je voulais
être pu aller aussi d où venaient aussi
faire savoir à toute l'europe que notre
lâcheté
n'était pas injustifiable yab fait en
france ces enfants seuls on tue le
pouvoir avec l'eau avec leur innocence
un passé sur le sentiment de peur je
fais un petit manque de
les peurs pour sauver notre honneur
alors pour sauver son honneur retrouvé
la liberté bucarest
comme toute la roumanie estime avoir
déjà donné beaucoup trop de vie dans les
hôpitaux bien sûr que l'on mesure que
l'on mesure l'ampleur du drame roumain
vrai pu le mesurer aujourd'hui wearever
aujourd'hui c'était le jour des
règlements de comptes à noël triste mais
aussi le début des bilans avec
l'accalmie des combats et la fourchette
de mort horrible mot varie entre 500 et
5000 car on est tous les tous les morts
ne sont pas apportés à l'hôpital on en
découvre partout et et il leur resterait
enfin dans les énergies que de bd morte
du cac reste bien sûr oui oui bien sûr
que nous sommes à bucarest mais parlons
que de bucarest est donc bruno gex
jean-françois hoffman mais j'ai un gars
parini sont allés dans un hôpital et
vous allez voir certaines images qui
sont assez pénibles mais c'est la
réalité
à l'appel de leur nom
les visages se décompose chaque jour
apporte son lot de victimes blessés ou
morts la liste est parfois long c'est
ici à l'hôpital des urgences de bucarest
que l'on informe les familles du sort de
leurs proches
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de morts dont
vous l'amendé dans cette morgue décor
ranger les uns à côté des autres par
terre par manque de place certains sont
là depuis deux jours
d'autres ont été tués l'année dernière
de simples passants des civils des
militaires mais aussi des hommes de la
securitate et cette police secrète de
ceausescu victimes des insurgés celui ci
a été marquée libyen aux palestiniens on
dit ici que des terroristes du proche
orient serait venu appuyer les hommes du
dictateur
une partie d'entre eux est fabriqué en
roumanie parce que ils connaissent bien
la langue roumaine mans habitude il leur
ensemble rassemble avec des roumains
mais avec des petites quand on te met le
problème
[Musique]
en commencement regarder et à dépister
ans dirige les les petites différences
sous bonne garde
2 dès qu'un suspect admis à l'hôpital
attachées à leur lit par des menottes et
des draps sous sédatifs et son domaine
de point de vue papiers d'identité ils
ont simulé la maladie pour être parmi
nous ont blessés sur l'efficacité des
drogues ils ont commencé à dire des mots
qui ne sont pas très exactement des
mondes méfiance et suspicion dans les
rues et le métro de bucarest contrôle
des véhicules fuient des personnes 25
ans de délation et de surveillance ont
appris aux roumains à se méfier des
espions de chaouchi est ce que ça vous
parliez de bilan tout à l'heure peut
être 1000 2000 5000 morts pour bucarest
on a parlé de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de morts pour l'ensemble de la
roumanie est ce que vous avez une
confirmation nous bien sûr il est
impossible de faire le décompte je vous
dis rien pour bucarest il y a
certainement beaucoup beaucoup de corps
qui sont encore dans des immeubles où il
ya eu des combats et on ne peut pas
pénétrer
merci patricia nous vous retrouvons bien
sûr avec toutes les équipes d'antenne 2
pour les prochaines émissions les
prochaines éditions du journal merci
patricia merci aux envoyés spéciaux de
l'antenne de peu à peu au fur et à
mesure que l'accalmie semble s'étendre
ce que nous confirmait patricia le
nouveau pouvoir se met en place sa
figure de proue semble être violent
iliescu qui fut il ya plus de 15 ans
secrétaire du comité central du pc room
alors qui sont ces hommes nouveaux
michel mompontet le nouveau pouvoir
politique roumain c'est d'abord un lieu
celui de sa naissance
le studio 4 de la télévision à lui
caresse ces deux-là coeur par heure ce
nouveau pouvoir a structuré motivés et
surtout organiser la révolte
le conseil du front de salut national à
39 membres un mélange fait d'anciens
communistes
il intègre et dissidents dans le premier
cas yann eliès qui sommes populaires et
dynamique de 59 ans est pourtant un
ancien haut fonctionnaire de chercher ce
coup mais huit ans de disgrâce loin des
pouvoirs l'ont rachetée au jeu des
roumains il est apparu au premier rang
du comité de salut dès vendredi matin
annonçant la fuite de chercher ce coup
l'autre homme fort de ce conseil ces
corneilles ou manescu l'ancien
représentant de la roumanie à l'onu lui
aussi ancien communiste passé par la
disgrâce les on le dit malade il a
disparu du devant de la scène depuis
vendredi dernier
l'autre face de ce conseil ait fait
d'intellectuels de dissidents comme
laszlo tokes 37 ans un pasteur roumain
qui est à l'origine des émeutes de
timisoara and opposant courageux du
temps de la toute-puissance de chercher
ce coup dont il un corner a bien sûr est
dans le même cas chercher ce coup n'aura
jamais réussi malgré toutes ses
tentatives et ses menaces à faire taire
la voix de la plus célèbre dissidente du
pays
enfin sergiu nicolaescu surnommée la
langue de long du cinéma roumain depuis
trois jours on le dit partout au combat
dans les rues il est la caution
populaire du conseil du fonds de salut
national
il fut le premier visage à paraître
vendredi
sur le petit écran de la télévision
roumaine libre dans une interview au
monde monsieur jsk où expliquent qu'ils
n'ont pas demandé d' aide militaire à
l'union soviétique qu'elle n'était pas
nécessaire il ajouté nous sommes en
contact constant avec le ministère des
affaires étrangères soviétique alors
jacques merlino on comprend un petit peu
mieux à la lumière de ces déclarations
dans une interview au monde comment a pu
se dérouler l'insurrection fond oui car
si on prend un peu de recul sur
l'ensemble de ces événements
on réalise assez vite qu'un élément
décisif de ces derniers jours et bien ce
fut le soutien à apporter à la
population par l'armée roumaine
sans ce soutien il est à peu près
certain que le soulèvement militaire
n'avait aucune chance d'aboutir
on le comprend aisément lorsque l'on
voit la férocité des hommes de la
securitate
alors pourquoi l'armée romaine et elle a
décidé si rapidement et en bloc de
soutenir le soulèvement populaire et
bien il y à une hypothèse qui circule
dans les milieux diplomatiques
c'est que d'une manière ou d'une autre
les soviétiques ont fait comprendre à
l'armée roumaine qu'elle pouvait-il y
aller il dispose pour cela de moyens
simples l'armée roumaine dans le cadre
du pacte de varsovie est en liaison
directe et constante avec moscou
les nouveaux dirigeants de la roumanie
connaissent assez bien les soviétiques
oui en tout cas yonne iliescu de l'homme
fort du comité de scène nationale a une
particularité qui mérite d'être souligné
il a fait ses études à l'école des
cadres à moscou et là bas il s'est lié
d'amitié avec un jeune étudiant
soviétique et ce jeune étudiant
politique s'appelait michael gorbatchev
et c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'il avait
gardé des très bonnes relations
personnelles avec gorbatchev qu'il fut
écarté du pouvoir en 1987 par chéreau se
secoue cet ensemble d'informations nous
permettent ce soir je prends un peu
mieux de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
en roumanie
merci jacques le spectacle du martyr ou
main sur toutes les télévisions du monde
a provoqué un gigantesque élan de
solidarité tout à l'heure un boeing de
l'armée ouest allemande s'est posé à
bucarest l'aide envoyée par la france
avec bernard kouchner arrive ce sont
maintenant des trains de camions qui
partent de toute la france pour la
roumanie
valérie fournier à l'église roumaine de
paris la douleur et la fierté là bas
chez eux tout manque
et l'on se réjouit de l'élan de
solidarité des français car ils viennent
nombreux dans les quatre centres de don
de la capitale des centres improvisés la
mairie du 12e ou ce local loué pour
l'occasion par équilibre dont le premier
camion vient d'arriver à timisoara la
ville martyre et qui s'apprête à en
faire partir jeudi cinq autres mais
avant il faut trier les dons de
vêtements de vivre et surtout de
médicaments trier sans se tromper
la province aussi répond à l'appel
un avion affrété par médecins sans
frontières vient de décoller de
montpellier avec 20 tonnes de matériel à
bord
annecy des dentistes des médecins
délivrent des ordonnances spéciale pour
que vous puissiez
jeter des antibiotiques dans les
pharmacies sans difficulté à rouen les
cheminots de la sncf soutenue par
amnistie internationale et médecins du
monde charge bénévolement un convoi de
wagons contenant 1300 tonnes de denrées
alimentaires et de matériel de premier
secours
donc toute la france un seul mot d'ordre
rapidité efficacité pour encourager tous
les joueurs à participer à cette action
fantastique en faveur de la roumanie est
aussi à leur dire qu'il faudra par la
suite les appeler à la reconstruction de
ce pays traditionnellement alliés à la
france n'est pas oubliée après mais dans
l'urgence le ministère de la solidarité
de la santé invite ceux qui veulent et
qu'ils ne savent pas où donner à se
rendre dans tous les hôpitaux pour les
dons de vêtements et de couvertures
non dans ce studio lionel jospin bonsoir
monsieur le ministre vous êtes premier
ministre par intérim en ce moment alors
nous allons faire le point sur l'action
de la france est ce que les français
font alors c'est bien effectivement
d'aider les roumains encore faut-il que
cette aide arrive bien
et encore faut-il qu'elles parviennent
comme il forme
oui je crois qu'on peut dire d'abord que
notre pays a été le premier des pays
européens à aider la roumanie que ce
soit par les organisations non
gouvernementales et la mobilisation de
l'opinion ou que ce soit par l'action du
gouvernement
le problème maintenant c'est d'être
efficace et c'est pourquoi nous devons
nous prendre des mesures pour nous
assurer que cette aide est utile arrive
effectivement soit bien centralisée on
nous recommandons plusieurs choses une
par les préfectures vont centralisée
d'autre part en ce qui concerne les
médicaments ou le petit matériel
chirurgical il est souhaitable de le
faire parvenir par les hôpitaux qui
elle-même centraliseront vers les
préfectures
nous envisageons d'organiser un train
plusieurs trains pour acheminer
acheminer cela dans l'ordre donc je
crois qu'il faut être à la hauteur de ce
formidable mouvement d'opinion en france
pour que les choses fonctionnent
correctement soit organisé qu'on envoie
ce qui est utile au moment où c'est
utile
le gouvernement français lui même
va aider de lui même les roumains en
plus de cette aide de toute la france
je crois que dès le 23 décembre c'est
avant tout ce nous avons envoyé il ya eu
d'une part les organisations non
gouvernementale médecins du monde
médecins sans frontières l'aide médicale
internationale mais aussi les structures
des pompiers de paris de la sécurité
civile l'équipe autour de bernard
kouchner est tous ces gens travaillent
ensemble et je voudrais d'ailleurs
précisé à cet égard que nous avons
répondu à toutes les demandes qui nous
ont été faites par les nouvelles
autorités roumaines et qu' aucune autre
demande d'une autre nature qu'une aide
humanitaire n'a été fait par les
roumains
je crois qu on comprend tout ce que les
roumains sont fiers malgré les épreuves
de se libérer eux-mêmes
lisez allusion tout à l'heure à propos
de l'union politique justement monsieur
jospin puisque vous parlez plus
généralement de la roumanie on a appris
au commencement ce journal que nicolas
ceausescu et sa femme avaient été
exécutés un commentaire bien jugé
difficile de faire un commentaire cette
mort était elle annoncée par le mystère
sur la situation où étaient ceausescu
naturellement on préfère toujours les
procès publics mais c'est des événements
tragiques et en même temps plein
d'espoir que connaît la roumanie
actuellement ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
le courage de son peuple ce qu'il faut
retenir aussi c'est ce conseil de salut
national qui se met en place avec lequel
nous sommes en contact régulier de même
que l'ensemble des ministères de la
défense des affaires étrangères de la
santé de l'intérieur autour de matignon
se réunissent tous les jours
actuellement pour suivre ces processus
et politiquement et sous forme de l'aide
dont je parlais tout à l'heure c'est un
événement qui vient de se produire
bon peut-être aurait-on souhaité que
ceausescu puisse être jugé et dire ce
qu'il avait à dire merci monsieur
ministre jean paul ii a évoqué les
souffrances de la roumanie dans son
message de noël c'était tout à l'heure à
rome bien sûr vatican d'ailleurs au
cours de ces cérémonies de grêle le
drame des roumains a été souvent évoqué
vous allez le voir isabelle bechler
aujourd'hui le pape jean paul ii a
étendu la leçon de la nativité je le
cite au mouvement de liberté naissante
dans la vieille europe avec une mention
toute particulière pour la roumanie
penny au seigneur la noble père de
roumanie qui célèbre ce noël dans le
trouble dans la douleur pour ton de vies
humaines tragiquement perdu et dont la
joie d'avoir repris le chemin de la
liberté
émotion et recueillement de part et
d'autre de la porte de brandebourg à
berlin
ici en fait la lumière la liberté la
communication retrouver tout comme dans
l'église du samaritain qui fut l'un des
berceaux les plus actifs du soulèvement
est-allemand une église qui étaient plus
fréquentes et il est vrai du temps des
grandeurs politique du nouveau forum
religion et politique aussi dans les
territoires occupés à beth ça roule l'un
des villages palestiniens où est né
l'intifada hôtes de marque pour la messe
de minuit de ce village à l'importante
communauté chrétienne
desmond toutou le prix nobel
sud-africains qui appelle à la paix
entre juifs des arabes nous soutenons la
lutte du peuple palestinien mais les
juifs aussi ont droit à leur état libre
et indépendant est toujours des mesures
de sécurité impressionnantes par tout en
israël où aucune célébration ne peut
jamais être considérée sans danger
l'ami noël d'un dictateur l'autre après
chauché secousses et noriega au panama
qui a mis fin à sa cavale mais lui il a
trouvé le moyen d'échapper à ce qu'il
poursuive en l'occurrence les américains
ils se sont en effet réfugiées à la
nonciature c'est-à-dire à l'ambassade du
vatican
traditionnellement le vatican protège
donc ceux qui se réfugient dans la
saison bassin pour les américains cette
fuite de noriega est une amère victoire
à washington
jacques bouchard les applaudissements
des cris de joie salue la fin de la
chasse à l'homme à panama
un manifestant confirme que noriega a
été forcé à la reddition
la nouvelle se répand comme une traînée
de poudre
alors que des troupes américaines se
déploie et prennent position autour de
la nonciature apostolique la phase des
tractations commencent entre les
autorités du panama les états unis et
l'ambassade vaticane qui hérite d'un
invité encombrants dont elle se serait
volontiers passé le président panaméen
ndar a exclu toute idée d' extradition
de noriega aux états unis notre
constitution dit-il nous l'interdît suis
en tournée auprès des gi's dick cheney
ministre américain de la défense
confirme la sphère est désormais entre
les mains des diplomates et des juristes
comme par enchantement la tension a
brusquement baissé à panama en cette
nuit de noël alors que les scènes de
pillage tendent à se raréfier et l'
incendie d'une des résidences de noriega
symbolise la chute de l'ancien dictateur
il s'agit maintenant de lui trouver un
pays d'asile et on parle notamment de
cuba de l'espagne ou du mexique
alors qu'ici à washington la maison
blanche déclarent ne pas renoncer à
faire traduire noriega en justice devant
un tribunal américain en amérique du sud
au brésil un prêtre français gabriel
mère a été assassinée à victoria il
avait 53 ans il travaillait depuis neuf
ans au brésil
son assassinat pourrait être politique
en france deux adolescents d'un lycée de
montargis sont mort d'une septicémie
foudroyante il avait 16 et 17 ans un
autre élève du même lycée et lui aussi
hospitalisé pour la même maladie la
préfecture dans un communiqué a appelé
les élèves de ce lycée à se présenter
dans les hôpitaux car il y à des
médicaments très efficaces pour soigner
la maladie dont souffrait ces
adolescents alors j'en ai les akyé c'est
une information grave gars sur est ce
que tous ces lycéens doivent réellement
s'inquiéter alors il faut d'abord dire
que ces enfants et adolescents sont
morts de méningite cérébrospinale qui en
a mille cas par an en france que c'est
une maladie qu'on connaît bien qui est
là finit parfois très mal son compte
puisse y faire grand chose et que ce qui
se passe là et je dirais se passe
généralement en hiver et au printemps et
c'est malheureusement je les rentre
guillemets banal la chose qui est
importante à dire c'est que la réaction
de la préfecture du loiret est
parfaitement inadaptées à la situation
la préfecture du web demande à 1700
enfants alors famille d'aller sur faire
des prêts le monde gorge dans les
hôpitaux
cette mesure est illusoire inefficace
elle va encombrer inutilement les
hôpitaux du loiret qui sont déjà
débordés et les médecins sont
particulièrement effarés de la décision
de la préfecture
en revanche ce qui est important c'est
premièrement de ne pas paniquer
deuxièmement sur de traiter ce qu'on
appelle les sujets contacts c'est à dire
les personnes de l'entourage proche de
ses enfants et ses adolescents entourage
proche ça veut dire la famille
éventuellement les camarades de classe
ou de dortoir le germe est très fragile
il passe notamment par les postillons
dans la gorge des autres personnes on
peut lire indiqué avec des antibiotiques
que l'on connaît très bien
robin piscine roxy trop mission quels
médecins connaissent et savent prescrire
une culture très rapide très court qui
permet de détruire le germe tout le
reste toutes les autres mesures sont
parfaitement illusoire on ne fait des
prélèvements de gorge que si dans
l'entourage très proche des gens qui ont
de la fièvre fermer les écoles les
casernes désaffectées c'est une mesure
psychologique qui n'a jamais prouvé son
efficacité
enfin dernier point c'est pour
d'habitude la dass es autorités
sanitaires du département qui donne son
opinion sur des questions comme ça ce
n'est surtout pas le travail du
secrétariat général de la préfecture
parce qu'il ya des termes médicaux a
précisé et des paniques à éviter et dans
cette affaire on a paniqué la population
on ne l'a pas informé
merci docteur de nous rassurer n'oubliez
pas que nous étions le 25 décembre
aujourd'hui jour de noël les événements
dramatiques de roumanie nous font
évidemment oublier cette fête de la
famille une fête qui n'en est pas
toujours une pour tout le monde même en
france ceux par exemple qui n'ont même
pas d'endroit pour dormir
c'est en france à paris simplement ils
sont quinze mille on les appelle les
sans domicile fixe
hier soir ils ont tout de même eu un
réveil au grâce au secours catholique
claude crespo comme les août
réveillonner
comme ceux qui ont un toit et de quoi se
nourrir partager avec d'autres
déshérités pour qui chaque jour est un
combat contre la solitude la faim la
misère
au menu ce soir d'un des champagnes un
moment de fête pour retrouver un moment
dignité le droit la fête c'est beau mais
si ce n'est que cinq minutes on l'a fait
ce bond pas des clochards des
personnages nous on se lave 350
bénévoles pour servir hier soir plus de
1000 sans domicile fixe pour marie
thérèse 15 ans ce sera son seul
réveillon les soudeurs toute l'année
alors
on s'amuse autant sacrifier une soirée
pour certains auront même pu écrire qui
a une famille qui a des amis qui souvent
ignorent tout de leur situation précaire
ensuite messe de noël
même pour ceux qui ne sont pas de
confession catholique et ceux qui n'ont
rien auront quand même une pensée pour
d'autres ailleurs hier encore et descend
liberté fixe
mes premières
finalement on est
cela nous amène à parler tout de suite
de la roumanie la roumanie avec ces deux
informations dont je viens de prendre
connaissance grâce à notre petit
ordinateur
alors tout d'abord tout d'abord le
dernier bilan
il y aurait eu soixante mille morts en
roumanie depuis le 15 décembre c'est le
tribunal militaire extraordinaire romain
celui qui a fait condamner à mort
cherchez scoop qui a annoncé cette
information à radio bucarest radio
bucarest qui était captée en
l'occurrence à vienne voilà donc un
premier bilan terry terrifiant soixante
mille morts
depuis donc le début des événements
c'était il y a dix jours à peine
et puis la deuxième information c'est à
propos de l'exécution de nicolae
ceausescu et sa femme elena je vous en
ai parlé en commençant ce journal le
journaliste qui parlait le monsieur qui
parlait donc à la télévision roumaine à
donner les motifs de l'exécution de la
condamnation à mort de nicolas chasser
school les motifs les voici
ceausescu et sa femme ont été exécutés
pour génocide noyautage de l'état vol de
biens publics destruction de l'économie
roumaine et tentative de fuite
voilà ce qu'a indiqué tout à l'heure
aussi radio bucarest et le speaker de la
télévision roumaine que vous venez de
voir à l'instant voilà c'est sur ces
deux informations que nous allons
refermer ce journal auparavant quelques
informations pratiques comme nous en
donnons chaque fois à la fin du journal
tout d'abord il y avait un tiercé
aujourd'hui on va voir tout de suite les
résultats le 9 là c'est le 8 je vous
laisse lire les rapports
c'était un kart et peut-être ou un
quinté je ne sais plus
quarté + voilà neuf as 8 et 14 la météo
tout de suite ce sera laurent romejko
philippe gatseau vous donnera les
dernières informations notamment de
roumanie
vers 23h20 à demain 20 heures
[Musique]
à